hi everyone I'm sorry and I'm Jeff and
today we're gonna be making Yanni yeah
so we have all our tools we got all our
materials and hopefully we're gonna make
something that looks like this
I think that's unlikely but we're gonna
try it's gonna be great we have an
instructional manual which I'm asked us
to start by getting this wire and
putting it into a general yarny shape so
let's get started
oh my God look at you you're manhandling
that thing oh my goodness that looks
exactly like the picture your face sorry
what are you bending company look baby
look words what I can't get in there
okay no you're right in the picture
that's definitely the case and you just
gonna take it and then give it a kiss
around it so what am I done second three
three my another Christy's make sure to
the internet why am I so weak okay this
kind of this is pretty that's pretty
that's that's [ __ ]
then we just twist then we just twist so
a really thick wire arm around in a
perfectly tight coil this is like seems
easy dream
okay so we've gone ahead like a face
well I wouldn't go that far
he has no neck but can I please point
out that Yanni has no neck so I'm pretty
sure with five whatever full time full
time hey you want to hear a joke about
string yeah so a string went to a bar
and then asked for a drink for the
bartender and the bartender was like I'm
sorry we don't serve drinks here so the
stream was like oh okay
so he went outside and undid himself and
paraded himself a bit and then he went
back inside and then the bartender was
like hey aren't you the string from
before and the string replied no I'm
afraid not
oh we should push some wool in his belly
oh yeah we should cut off a shitload of
wool putting in his tummy yeah
you should use that one that's a good
idea no it's just like straight up not
always charge it sometimes well I
appreciate know what to do instructions
okay just sometimes very life you need
to improvise a bit
wait Yanni a free fish unravel
adventures where hard I'm Phil no just
[ __ ] no yeah like out down you really
little so cool
Yanni's been hitting the gym oh yeah but
isn't it wrong every day is funny this
is the vice - it's your name
Yanni's local hahaha he's not a talented
he's got no that's not my point you did
is wrong
don't listen to yourself you have no
idea you know what this reminds me what
there's little hot pot like noodle
things oh yeah you look so scary that's
a food at all yes thanks he looks like a
mummy
I think he's supposed to
I
s'alright have faith in our creation
Jess we made this Yianni with blow he's
a monster with Frankenstein we're dr.
Frankenstein almond the townspeople go
throw rocks at him no it's fine gonna
burn him with fire
I reckon less that's a pretty good I
mean it definitely looks like white wool
on top of red wolf s are asking me
presenting yoni Yahoo his long-lost
special brother he's nice he's a johnny
is just as cool he's just as good and
has he's a little out of our way
yeah but he's just every way with his
heart of gold and white wool is tummy
okay
you